CU men naturally flock to beauty and
it's so funny God I'm so tired of the
pandering and you telling these women
they look younger they don't no you
don't look that young on the carnivore
diet no you don't look that young on the
keto diet no you didn't get some Botox
and not look older you guys all look old
you look your age you might look good
for your age but you still look your age
and these guys just Pander you cuz
they're nice none of these guys tell you
the truth they want to sleep with you
even at 60 they'll still want to sleep
with you but no notice how she didn't
say commit you know just because you can
get guys to sleep with that's not even a
compliment that's not that's not an
accomplishment I see obese women get men
to sleep with them it doesn't mean
anything when you get older you get less
attractive men are not as interested and
the quality of men that you can get goes
down I don't I don't make the rules this
this is part of life and older women
used to actually tell the truth to
younger women so they didn't have to
live in delusion for a lifetime